we have this other story that's really
funny actually and this exemplifies the
the great problem check this out
twitter labels indiana ag's tweet of
valentine's day meme
that election was stolen from trump this
is hilarious
todd rokita tweeted happy valentine's
day and there's an image that says you
stole my heart like a 2020 election
happy valentine's day and twitter says
this claim of election fraud is disputed
and this tweet can't be replied to
retweeted or liked due to a risk of
violence
chef's kiss memes it's it's a meme
he's not literally saying there was
fraud he's mocking the idea it's donald
trump as a cartoon and he's making fun
of it
you can't even post memes yeah they went
after a couple my memes too on instagram
and twitter
just deleted them and i didn't even know
and i'm like wait what's going on here
why
me i mean they're satirical they're
meant to be funny that's funny that
that's that's
that seriously i don't think that's
going that's not going to make anyone
violent at all and and now we're at a
phase where instagram just announced a
few days ago
that they're going to be going and
snooping through your dms your private
messages
looking for hate speech to go after
that's not new
i know but them publicly announcing it
is new we have to acknowledge the
reality that uh that these platforms are
i think we've all been talking about
this
they have a form of concentrated
political power
akin to basically a loaded gun on the
table they swing elections they sway
elections so what do we do about it
right that's what everyone
says to to me it's like okay stop
complaining be brave do something
i i i kind of agree with you i think
it's
exposing the reality and
we need an army of whistleblowers inside
big tech well you know
i've said this several times i think the
work you guys do is some of the most
important work we have right now
in like just in your show brought us
richard hopkins last time i was on the
show
the mailman from uh from um pennsylvania
erie pennsylvania
sent us an email after watching your
show
and blew the whistle on the postal
service uh
that's all you man i mean we're just a
bunch of people who sit down sitting
around talking about stuff on the
internet but for whatever reason he
watches your show
more than the other show and he came to
prairie veritas veritas tips at
protonmail.com awesome
shameless plug that's v-e-r-i-t-a-s tips
at protonmail.com it's encrypted
hopefully the nsa is not intercepting
that email
and uh and that richard came to us and
richard lost his job
tim richard was fired from the postal
service first he was suspended then he
was fired by the way
i think that's important because he has
skin in the game he's an actual person
who's going to lose his
career for the public's right to know
something he's not just saying something
he's giving up his livelihood here's
here's why i say what you do is so
important
and actually why what you know richard
and others have done is
even more important i mean for one you
can't do your job unless there's brave
people willing to stand up and work with
you to get that information out
more importantly those brave people who
are standing up are creating this
atmosphere
where these big shots these fat cats
these corrupt individuals now to keep
looking over their shoulders wondering
who's going to say you can't do that i'm
going to i'm essentially going to blow
the whistle
it's like you were mentioning earlier
you know people at facebook now have to
worry
who's the person there who's going to
share what they're saying luke when you
when they go to look at dms which is
unconscionable and unethical for someone
to browse private dms
in the back of that whatever engineer
coder's mind is
wait before i look at the dm should i be
worried if someone's looking at me
that that that psychological effect
exactly and this is why they don't
have any transparency or accountability
to their actions because if they did
people would know what they can and
cannot say
they don't want you knowing it because
they want this fear effect they want
this chilling effect
where you have to worry about your butt
and worry about what you're thinking
about
because when you're when you're
censoring words you're censoring what
people can think essentially
and we also have to understand on the
bigger point here these are not
private capitalistic entrepreneurship
organizations you look at the seed
funding liquid there came from look
right now at their tax incentives the
visa programs
their data sharing surveillance programs
the government contracts that they
receive
these are entities that are in line with
a lot of government institutions that
are working hand-in-hand
with government is downstream from these
institutions yes and then they work hand
in hand
and they're pushing this agenda together
and i think once we address
that we have to understand these are not
just private entities that are private
companies pick and choose they're not
they're not that at all they are
monopolies at least that's a great
observation i was thinking as we were
talking that there could be some
software developer that's like i'm going
to blow the whistle on facebook i'm
going to deliver all the code to project
veritas
that wouldn't work because unless we use
the government to regulate these people
and to actually change the software
license uh and do it right
you could get rid of the code and they
can just change it so
we have to we have to acknowledge that
these guys are are basically quasi
government
organizations and should be treated such
yeah yeah well
for the time being i mean things are
demoralizing
yeah i want to leave twitter i don't
want to leave twitter but when i see the
way they're treating you
like this ridiculous well i can tell you
right now there's someone watching this
who does work for twitter or google or
facebook i guarantee it
and we have so many sources and
whistleblowers coming to us right now
it's beyond
what you can fathom i mean we have
untold dozens
over a hundred whistleblowers right now
recording watching
i'm talking about the ceos of these
companies and if you're watching this
right now
just like just like richard hopkins a
few months ago
send us a note i think the solution is
exposure i think they don't fear the
united states government anymore
these all these people these politicians
are they they almost like they suck up
to cnn they
all they ever do is go on cnn i don't
even know what these congress critters
actually
do what do they actually do well because
all i ever see them doing
is going on instagram which is owned by
by mike zuckerberg
and going on television do they actually
create any laws i guess they don't
because government is in a state of
sclerosis so they can't pass legislation
so all they do is go on tech platforms
they are
beholden to tech they suck on the teat
of big tech where would aoc be without
twitter and instagram nowhere all the
government
just like alexander sultan eaton said uh
the the media has more power than all
three branches of the government and
what laws are they beholden to
when they say you are not allowed to
talk about this
or that it is akin to the united states
supreme court
changing the constitution and saying uh
you know first i'm going to apply except
when you talk about you know
applesauce you wanna know something
really crazy that i was reading and guys
definitely if you're listening fact
check me on this one i was reading some
a post as a conservative post to this
that trump's own lawyer in the
impeachment trial
believed the very fine people hoax up
until he had to research the evidence
to defend donald trump then realized the
media
had been selectively editing what trump
had said and trump definitively
denounced white supremacy
after after charlottesville and well the
media cuts it out of context like they
did with the shinzo abe fish feeding
thing
and this lawyer didn't know that about
trump until he was investigating because
he had to go over the evidence how many
people think they're informed
because they read the news they read
what facebook allows to be shared
and they actually are just being fed
garbage the amount of fake news
disinformation and propaganda out there
is
absolutely insane to even fathom
sometimes uh it's like 1984 two plus two
equals five is just keep being repeated
you know that's a real thing though
right there i know i know it's i've seen
i've seen everything i've seen it unfold
but james the one question i really
wanted to ask you here when you got hit
by twitter
was there any alternative social media
platform that you were looking into
fully transitioning
away from twitter so i i take a unique
position on this because
i i i may take a stance that
tim you don't agree with her luke you
don't agree with i think that content is
king
that that i i believe in distribution by
proxy in other words if they ban me
everywhere
which everyone's warning me about okay
whatever they ban me everywhere and i
get a and i get a hidden camera video of
a federal judge taking a bribe
that's a 30-second video i would simply
send an email
to my 500 000 people on my email list
saying please download this video and
upload it to your twitter
and they can't ban every so content is
king content not
platform is king i've always believed
that everyone wants to create another
platform
i i i thought this in the back of my
head about parlor by the way parlor got
banned
okay we're going to create another
parlor apollo's back parlor's back
but but and then i saw a parlor banned
milo today and now he's back oh he's
back to okay well
there's all these updates about the
platform but at the end of the day
content is king i didn't coin that
phrase that was uh
the viacom ceo i forgot his name but i
i i believe that um what was going
through my mind luke was that
content is king a good story will effuse
its way
and distribute it you know its way sort
of like the black goo
in the movie prometheus it will just
sort of
get out there and there'll be a new
paradigm i don't know what the name of
the next or the future platform will be
but what i do know
is a good story is always lurking behind
every
corner and and again distribution by
proxy so telegram
we had 4 000 followers a couple weeks
ago now we have 350 000 followers
and what we'll do is we'll send a vimeo
link and say please download this clip
and upload it into your twitter so if
we're banned on twitter
citizens can can can do what are they
going to ban
everyone they can't do that this is the
funny thing you know
when tiktok had a bullying problem
there were people being mocked for their
appearance or their weight
they realized something whereas twitter
bans the hate speech
to protect the minority tick tock
realized well
if we want to stop the bullying and we
ban say
a thousand people bullying this person
that's a thousand users we
lose in our annual reports for
shareholders why don't we ban the person
being
bullied then there's no more bullying so
tic tac actually targeted
the person who was a victim of the of
the insults
that was clever in the uh i bring that
up just because
in the instance of twitter well they
can't ban everybody because then they're
gonna have to issue a report saying we
lost x many users
this quarter oh we banned them because
we didn't like what they had to say
yeah and they can't ban us today because
if they ban us for the zuckerberg story
every reporter that talks about it will
have to say
there's no doxing here it's zuckerberg
on tape you know you know the problem is
right now though
it's not fun anymore it's not what it's
not fun
part twitter used to be fun oh it's
shareable you but they're getting rid of
interesting people
seeing a trump tweet was hilarious you
know the journalists would have panic
attacks when trump would tweet that's
weird
but i thought it would be funny when
trump would tweet something really silly
you know
like not that he should have most of the
time but
sometimes he would tweet funny and silly
things what did he tweet oh yeah when
elizabeth warren was drinking the beer
remember this
and her husband walks up and then she's
like thanks for being here
trump tweets what do you mean he's
supposed to be there it's his house that
was hilarious
it made it made it exciting they're
getting rid of anything that's that's
like even remotely interesting on the
platform
i mean and if they ban us today for
publishing a video tape of zuckerberg
every reporter who reports on the ban
will have to include the facts about
what mark zuckerberg said that's why
they won't ban us
tim i think there's a lot to this whole
litigation
i mean that my producer just texted me
that's genius tim
helping helping others with a litigation
fund that's a really
important idea because so many people
get defamed
and and we have a recourse in in in the
theory of defamation
law especially if they're not public
figures and i'm a public figure i have
to prove what's called actual malice i
have to prove the person
knew they were lying about me when they
lied but a non-public figure tim
if you're railroaded discovery this is a
really good
idea i don't i think the people the
reason people haven't done this is
because they don't know they can do it
and it takes i i call it balls resources
and willpower
balls or or
and i think it's a great idea i think
it's an excellent idea called the
people's defamation fund pdf
yeah pdf files pdf yeah and people
already you know it's already in the
back of their mind pdf they know well
they say the idea is one percent of it
99 is the execution but still i think if
you launched uh
not a gofundme because they would ban
you into that yeah but if you launched a
any one of these other pla any any other
fundraisers you'd instantly raise enough
to just
hire uh an executive manager or whatever
to run the fund
listen i'm gonna say it on your show
right now if we get the new york times
to give us money which i
i'm betting my reputation on it so it's
going to happen we're going to use some
of those proceeds to start this um
this idea that you have i like this idea
i mean you mean the idea that i brought
up
the idea that you have it doesn't matter
but i named it but another thing to
i mean i remember starting off and i was
when i was still just you know
no one not a big reputation getting
slandered and attacked by the mainstream
media
and also other instances where they
literally took
my videos that i did my live reporting
on protest
and they claimed it as theirs so many
times didn't they call you like a
non-shrinking violet or something
yes that was the new york times what was
that quote that was an of the uh
lukadowski is armed with a video camera
and a youtube channel and definitely is
not
a shrinking violet nice uh that was the
new york times perspective
and that was actually you know fair
reporting on their part which was really
interesting because they actually quoted
me correctly when other news
organizations literally took
quotes out of context put them together
to make them sound bad
or as if i was pushing for some kind of
violent action which i
of course never was i believe in total
non-violence always have always have
advocated for that but but for them
especially when i was starting off
especially when i didn't have a big
following
they would just take everything i did
take my live reporting take my photos
take my videos claim it as
theirs and then when i became prominent
they started slandering me and i'm like
what's going on here
i actually started talking to some
lawyers and uh
let's just say they don't steal my
videos they don't steal my photos
anymore but a lot has changed in the
last seven eight years
the lot the world has changed the new
york times went real
yeah we were talking about this
yesterday with will because you know
even
even with that new york times uh you
know weapons of mass destruction lie
there is still some kind of
understanding that the new york times
tries to tell the story and even then
when they caught when they got caught
with the wmds they they admitted it they
talked about it
they they there were some repercussions
behind it
miller yeah yeah they they faced some
real actions because of that uh
still not enough comparatively to the
lie that they sold the american public
and the hundreds of thousands of people
that died and the
radicalization and immigration crisis
that came out of it
but but still not enough but still there
was still this kind of veil
understanding that
that that they're trying that they made
a mistake that that that you know
they're going to do their best they even
interviewed me a couple times and they
did
honest real reporting but but now all of
that's gone
uh that whole perception that whole
understanding that they're even trying
they're not even trying anymore
they're blatantly slapping the american
people upside the face
they're obsessing about race they're
obsessing about all this other stuff
that divide and conquers us so we fight
each other and we don't focus on the
real issues the actual things that do
affect us
especially after 2012 their their
decline is evident and
they're not the same new york times that
they're known for thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you